well hello reject nation I am Greg Elbe
with me is Tara Ericsson Tara Eriksen is
here people follow her the terror
Ericsson YouTube yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah hi-yah hi-yah I mean okay well tear
up we saw a video called eight days in
the Philippines but I told you in that
video that we normal I don't really
check out these commercials of the
Filipino fan base tends to send over to
us yeah one of the most popular Filipino
chain restaurants in America and I'm
assuming the Philippines - mm-hmm is a
place called jollibee this one we're
gonna watch because there's a Jollibee
in my neighborhood always like what is
that that's a driver I'm not joking
it's a little red face then they have
yeah yeah right great food it's
fantastic food jelly beans great now be
prepared is called perfect pairs I have
no idea what this one's about but here's
what I know about Jollibee okay they
tend to go for a little bit on the
sensitive side it tend to go for like
short stories instead of a ad this is
commercials four minutes long
okay yeah oh boy wow they are really
hitting it hitting yeah so get ready to
feel okay I got all the fields ready
[Music]
in eco Manila muta no unit I'll make a
decision
[Laughter]
[Music]
in eco model amudha no unit I'll make it
as a jolly be college Taiwan Lala best
friends the tyre parasite because I
sorry Rico he's the one
[Music]
in peak or a melody Moodle no una medida
[Music]
freebees there
at that moment and I'm cool I wasn't the
one you wanted to spend the rest of your
life with
[Music]
Berube nanaho that i will still be your
friend
I will always support you
[Music]
I will be there whenever you need me
[Music]
oh it's see it's like oh there's another
commercial tell you NASA
[Music]
I hung up quinna
[Music]
I'll always be just your friend oh
that's so painful I
[Music]
is this see nothing
[Music]
Zanna
you go VIN
oh wow that's that's quick
means and Bella comedy leave it alone
dad I think they are perfect as I want
white
[Music]
I kind of wanted it to like and actually
got married and they wanted them to just
be friends yeah and then it's like the
perfect pair like the perfect pair of
friendship even though it hurt her but
she's like you love me so much then she
get over it then that means he got
divorced right no made me cry for a
second I was getting a little teary-eyed
too cuz I've been friend-zoned for sure
yeah it's a painful experience when you
really head over heels for someone who's
not into you and consider you their best
friend now I've definitely been there I
fell for that I usually feel like guys
in stories are the ones who were
friend-zoned I know there's stories for
girls or friendzone but I realize within
the story so yes I appreciate it
oh it's the girl who's friendzone this
guy Larry really good-looking
I can't I mean I don't know I don't know
he's not my type
yeah but he seems like a cute guy not
too hot woman just pining over yeah
they're just ready they're ready to put
a rock on it yeah exactly no I prefer
the first girl if we're just going off
the looks yeah yeah me too
well I think they're both pretty but I
prefer the first girl to only because
she's cool she was just an emotional
investment and it's obvious he should
have chosen her are right at the
beginning I think they're just that
ending as much as there's a party that's
like well I am happy they got together
at the same time though everything
seemed kind of realistic until that
weight where it realistic where she
could have walked away they still remain
friends and he was still married at the
chick enjoy Jollibee cuz to just show up
what happened well I mean I guess he
left his wife so he could be with her
was instead of calling her texting her
sending her a Facebook message or
instagramming her he decided I know I'll
find her a jalebi that's the beauty of
Jollibee he was still the same age
Gregory what do you mean he's the same
age he was the same age when he was
later at the Jolly baby Mike I'll find
her there
would have been at least give me a break
he didn't like marry that girl and then
leave her two weeks later well maybe he
just took the ring off and he was in the
middle of a divorce process jerk sure
there's so many bad down right now did
you say how you should be cry and love
the wedding to be like there are perfect
pairs and sometimes we're all gonna be
okay with it but you gotta Jollibee and
you'll be happy that way this is the
most controversial jollibee commercial
ending is so divisive then I feel kind
of just really bad for the woman he
married like wasted the lady that you
married time you know it's like all
confusing
hey man relationships are tough though
man we never know that's the whole point
it is like what is that what is the
little thing at the end marriage is
tough it hasn't it says marriage is
tough but jollibee will fix it there's a
perfect time to find your perfect pair
so maybe they just weren't meant to be a
pair at the time but they had to go
through these obstacles in order to get
there I agree I think the way that it
should have ended is that it wasn't him
it was a different guy that gave the
same look that the first guy gave to his
wife and it was a different guy to her
and then she's like is this seat taken
and he's like no and then it was a
different guy being like and I hope
you're not but jokingly cuz he's so
attractive to her and then she finds her
other different pair that actually would
have been fantastic see now besides the
last 15 seconds of this job what did you
think of the rest of it all of it was
great and there's a perfect time to find
your perfect pair is a great little
phrase that they got going on little
catch phrase yeah so every time I say
did somebody who's like yeah I'm single
or whatever my friends I feel like
theirs are perfect to find your perfect
pair let's go Charlie yeah exactly
I don't know identified a lot with the
position she was friendzone
been there man it sucks it totally sucks
especially if you have to see them with
the other oh that's ok that's like you
can't you can't do anything you just
like shaking and your gut hurts and you
feel like you want to projectile vomit
over everything
uncomfortable heart clenching and a lot
of sarcasm to block it that's a weird
sweat in weird places it's tough it's
tough man Jollibee challenges you man
they challenge you with their fried
chicken and french fries and the good
burgers oh and their rice right oh yes
Filipino boom dude you gotta go I'm
gonna die and I always drive by it and
I'm like what is that cuz it's like old
red be looking thing comment if you want
Tara because her experience yeah yeah
okay comment I'll wait on it I won't go
today I'll wait to see if anybody wants
to see me go to jollibee first yes I
haven't been to jollibee in a few years
when I was younger I've been a few times
did you like it was it good I did I have
a burger and fries cuz I'm in Filipino
born in America I've never tried their
chicken it looks good looks delicious
that commercials make it look fantastic
well thank you Filipino Jack's I even
got it now you just made enough yeah
Filipino Jack's thank you for tuning in
today's video you can subscribe to the
real rejects and you can check out Tara
Erickson on Tara Erickson YouTube
channel and she is Tara Erickson on
Twitter Instagram and check out her
patron at our patreon at the real
rejects - for exclusive goodies goodbye